if I wanted to go a very long distance
the first thing I do is grow the ruler
to shrink the distance then go the
distance under that ruler and then I'd
shrink the ruler back
so when you talk about things like oh
these things are behaving like nothing
I've ever seen
well there are a couple things that I'm
worried about if these things are real
one is
does somebody else know how to grow
rulers and Shrink rulers and grow
watches and Shrink watches speed them up
slow them down in order to get in
control of the thing that we thought was
space time
the next issue is are there multiple
temporal dimensions
so Eric
your friend has had too much coffee
believes that they're either six or four
extra temporal dimensions and whatever
isn't temporal is spatial so it's either
four plus six or six plus four extra
Dimensions split between time and space
if that's true try to imagine
extra dimensional
Engineers who have full access to
something where there's no Arrow of time
the only time there's an arrow of time
is if time is one dimensional
time is two-dimensional you have like
a Whirlpool of time which is either
clockwise or counterclockwise if it's
three-dimensional you have a right hand
rule of time and there's a left hand
rule of time these are called
orientations
my belief is
that we may be looking at something that
has access to either four or six
additional dimensions and again I'm
reading this off of
a page of equations and
notes and so you know what they mean in
physical reality in other words if this
thing on the page is true
holy [__]
on the other hand if it's just some
geometry then you don't worry about it
you say okay well extra Dimensions I can
think in 17 or three or what it doesn't
matter
it's not that hard to think in higher
dimensions spatially for people who do
what I do
almost none of us can think in multiple
temporal Dimensions there's one guy in
Los Angeles at USC called Yitzhak bars
Turkish Jew
who keeps talking about two-time physics
and I've spoken to him
but multiple temporal Dimensions would
be a decisive game changer
in terms of changing everything that we
know about the world and what would be
the technology that someone could use to
access that
because well that's the big thing I know
I know I know
you think about it
you're you and I are both old enough to
remember cassette tapes and vinyl albums
on a cassette tape you've played your
favorite album all the way through like
Dark Side of the Moon and you want to
play it again
you have to rewind through every song
you just played and you hear me right
but that doesn't happen on an album
towards the end of the turntable time
you would just the stylus would pick up
it would skip over all the stuff that
you didn't want to hear again
and it would go back to some track that
you did
imagine you could do that with time you
didn't have to go back through time to
go back in time
do I even know what I mean not not
really I'm sort of at the edge of where
I can actually say things but you see
all of physics proceeds from the time
from the Assumption the time is one
dimensional we have this thing called
deterministic propagation so if you take
quantum mechanics they're really two
rules one is completely deterministic
with no probability Theory you've got a
system you know it's initial conditions
and you say if I know the laws of
physics I should be able to figure out
where this is
you know I take this lighter and I throw
it up and I catch it
and it described a parabola okay
initial condition propagation I measure
it it's completely determined by the
point of release
in quantum mechanics you have the second
thing called Quantum measurement
and that is this weird probabilistic
thing that nobody understands everybody
says if you think you understand the
quantum you don't understand it it's
mind-blowing blah blah blah
but the first part of it is where we're
trying to fit gravity
and when we quantize it I don't think
gravity goes in that slot I think that
what you do is you don't quantize
gravity you harmonize gravity gravity is
the Observer
we say well when you make an observation
well who's doing the observation is Joe
doing the observation is Jamie doing the
observation who's doing this observation
who has the right to use the second rule
for collapsing the state Vector with
Schrodinger's Cat and all entanglement
weirdness
well I think it's gravity
I think that part of the story is is
that gravity is the Observer through
something called a pullback operation
and when you realize that you realize
that you don't naively quantize Gravity
the way you quantize everything else in
fact gravity is the only field
living on the successor to space-time if
I'm correct there are two spaces called
X and Y all the cool stuff in here the
electrons the quarks that make up
everything that you and I are
is living on y except for the metric
the rulers and the protractors which
lives on X which is how you keep gravity
separate and the unification is the
unification of these two things in a
structure called a bundle now people
will go over this
and I'm sure professors will say well
this is what Eric was saying well he's
full of [__] no no he's actually making
a point
this story about space-time engineering
where you don't use the Einstein field
equations because you're using the
successor Theory rather than in the
Einstein theory
the entire planet was pulling on you
when you needed to go pee
and your legs I mean obviously buff
you're fit you just pulled against an
entire planet to get out of your chair
and you won
that's how weak gravity is that's how
space and time is barely Bent by all of
Earth
now you're going to tell me about an
alcubieri warp drive where okay no
here's what's going on the ship is
inside of this little bubble of warping
no it isn't
if somebody's space-time engineering and
they can get here from very far away
they're not using general relativity in
the standard model my friends
they're using a successive Theory and we
have become [__] we are not going to
look at successor theories because we've
all learned the lesson that everybody
who tries to bet against the standard
model loses everybody who bets against
general relativity loses
[Music]